ce monde 1
concernant la jeunesse est les deux
assurent révolutionnaire mais dans ce
monde d'anarchie la réelle révolution
c'est la droite nationale qui est porté
par marine le pen
[Musique]
il avait déjà
ici pour lire avec plus grand intérêt
alors vous souhaite une bonne journée
à écouter nous ne sommes pas ennemis
nous ne sommes quatre jacques serre j'ai
beaucoup apprécié les premiers les
écrits d'eric zemmour et c'est vrai
qu'en tant qu'homme politique il ya
quand même moins au niveau que d'autres
quand marine le pen sera au deuxième
tour vous associez les
devants 6 et marinés et nous devancer
amertume je préfère voter pour que pour
emmanuel mais marine le pen a beaucoup
plus de chances de remporter la victoire
non gardé le même temps l'élection de
dimanche
ça nous arrive bien bien souvent de
discuter avec des gens qui n'ont pas
forcément les mêmes idées que nous et
puis au détour d'une discussion parfois
on arrive à les faire sur la vie vous
appréciez le programme du rassemblement
social pour 2022
pensez à prendre est plutôt comme tu es
deuxième comme pour soutenir le combat
blanc et un moment tu passes ta promis
ok le camion en tout cas si vous nous
soutenez déjà dans les urnes monsieur
c'est une grande avancée
vous savez la vallée vigile est gagné
par le rassemblement national de
plusieurs années puisque les sondages
puisque 73% et parfois jusqu'à 80 % des
français en ont assez de la subversion
migratoires qui le subissent tous les
jours
[Musique]
on est en plus du groupe bougival dans
les yvelines
c'est un endroit où malheureusement j'ai
été contraint de dormir plusieurs jours
donc à cet endroit là exactement
j'ai dormi ici deux nuits et donc j'ai
passé trois jours ce qui paraît peu mais
je vous garantis que ça fait une
éternité quand vous les vivez dès lors
que vous arrivez dans la rue la première
des réactions c'est la honte je me
rappelle d'une dame qui étaient assez
âgés qui est passé qui s'est arrêté pour
me regarder et j'ai jamais eu un aussi
long de ma vie qu'en croisant son regard
[Musique]
m'avait expliqué qu'en france nous
laissions pas les gens dormir dehors et
force est de constater que c'était
totalement faux puisque je travaillais
alors en tant que manutentionnaire de
nuit dans une grande firme de
supermarchés et j'avais un de mes
collègues fraîchement arrivé d'erythrée
qui lui avait en appartement un t3 dans
les environs à chatou et qui désireux de
faire venir sa famille avait sollicité
l'état pour avoir quelque chose de plus
grand et en parallèle c'est vrai que
lorsque je suis venu ici malheureusement
moi je n'avais droit à rien et j'ai reçu
cette phrase qui fait toujours qui fait
toujours résonance dans mon coeur
monsieur rivière vous êtes français vous
avez de la famille ici quelqu'un pourra
peut-être vous héberger
[Musique]
j'ai tout simplement pris une carte au
rassemblement national parce que c'était
le parti qui défend des les valeurs
traditionnelles qui défendez la famille
la patrie
l'identité française ne m'en suis jamais
caché pour moi c'est une fierté d'être
patriote vous êtes fier d'être français
c'est à dire de le dire
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que j'ai
rencontré jean marie le pen à montretout
dans son bureau bon c'est une photo
somme toute assez classique où on rigole
c'était à l'occasion d'une rencontre il
me rend compte tout simplement puis on
s'est fait on s'était fait des blagues
c'est vrai que c'était assez drôle
ça c'est à l'occasion des élections
régionales sur laquelle j'étais
positionner dans les ive et sur les de
jordan marc vella
un ostracisme et puis des invectives
habituel qui prennent forme de lanières
physique lorsqu'on vous arrache vos
affiches et que vous fait mon stage de
moustache de nasik la droite nationale
ne reçoit pas de conseil ou de remarques
de n'importe qui sur ce sujet là que
j'ai aucun premier extrait
[Musique]
voyez comme une alchimie de son
entregent
comment
verrez plus que de la politique vraiment
des amis
prennent pas aux avis
[Musique]
j'avais vu le slogan un peu le chapeau
général de notre campagne qui rendre aux
français leur pays et leur argent vous
êtes une génération qui allait être
amené dans les prochaines années à
gouverner à prendre des décisions
maintenant on est là pour passer à
l'action et c'est évidemment maintenant
votre rôle que de prendre votre destin
en main et que d'être gelée se faire
dans les prochains mois les futurs
députés et peut-être les futurs
ministres de marine le pen bon courage
bonne campagne à tous et on se
[Applaudissements]
respecte il aura l'occasion peut-être
d'être élu parce que c'est quand on est
élu qu'à un moment donné on peut changez
agir et elle prendre des décisions mais
c'est vrai que le rassemblement national
a historiquement toujours été partie qui
accorde une chance et une opportunité à
la jeunesse d'opportunités de prendre
son destin en main de prendre des
décisions et on a beaucoup de jeunes
mères de jeunes parlementaires et
probablement que tu sera long et
plusieurs députés what you want
[Musique]